>> EACH COUNT OF CONTEMPT OF
CONGRESS CARRIES A MINIMUM OF 30
DAYS AND MAXIMUM OF ONE YEAR IN
JAIL.
>>> THE WYOMING REPUBLICAN PARTY
SENDING A MESSAGE TO
CONGRESSWOMAN LIZ CHENEY FOR
SPEAKING OUT AGAINST FORMER
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
STATE GOP LEADERS VOTED TO NO
LONGER RECOGNIZE HER AS A MEMBER
OF THE PARTY AS SHE WORKS ON THE
JANUARY 6th COMMITTEE
INVESTIGATING THE INSURRECTION
AND PUSHING TO HOLD TRUMP
ACCOUNTABLE.
SHE'S NOT THE ONLY REPUBLICAN
WHO BLAMED TRUMP FOR THE ATTACK
ON THE CAPITOL.
CHRIS CHRISTIE SAYS IT STEMMED
FROM THE BIG LIE OF THE 2020
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION WAS
STOLEN.
HE HAS A NEW BOOK OUT TODAY.
GOVERNOR, THANK YOU FOR TAKING
THE TIME THIS MORNING.
>> THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME, JIM.
APPRECIATE IT.
>> THERE IS A UNIFORM RESPONSE
IN TODAY'S REPUBLICAN PARTY TO
LIZ CHENEY, YOU SEE HER KICKED
OUT OF REPUBLICAN PARTY, ALREADY
KICKED OUT OF THE HOUSE
REPUBLICAN LEADERSHIP.
THE FOLKS WHO VOTED FOR THE
INFRASTRUCTURE BILL, THE FOLKS
WHO VOTED TO IMPEACH DONALD
TRUMP, THEY GET PUNISHED BY THE
PARTY.
I WONDER, IS THERE A PLACE IN
THE CURRENT GOP FOR THE LIZ
CHENEYS OF THE WORLD, FOR
YOURSELF, AND WHAT IS THAT
PLACE?
>> WELL, LOOK, YOU KNOW, I CAN'T
SPEAK FOR LIZ.
LIZ DOES A GOOD JOB SPEAKING FOR
HERSELF.
WHAT I'LL SAY TO YOU IS I'M ALL
ABOUT OUR PARTY.
THIS BOOK IS ALL ABOUT OUR PARTY
MOVING FORWARD FROM WHERE WE ARE
NOW, TO BE AN EFFECTIVE CONTRAST
TO THE DEMOCRATS AND THE
POLICIES THAT ARE BEING PUT
FORWARD BY JOE BIDEN AND KAMALA
HARRIS.
BUT TO DO THAT, WE HAVE TO BE
TRUTHFUL, WE HAVE TO STOP
LOOKING BACKWARDS.
WE HAVE TO STOP GRIEVANCE
POLITICS AND VENDETTA POLITICS
AND WHAT WE HAVE TO DO IS TALK
ABOUT THE CONCERNS OF THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
AND WHEN THE REPUBLICAN PARTY
DID THAT TWO WEEKS AGO IN
VIRGINIA, GLENN YOUNGKIN WAS
ELECTED GOVERNOR.
AND CAME VERY CLOSE TO ELECTING
ANOTHER REPUBLICAN GOVERNOR IN
MY HOME STATE, BUT EVEN IN MY
HOME STATE WE WON SEATS IN THE
LEGISLATURE IN BOTH HOUSES BY
TALKING ABOUT A FORWARD LOOKING
AGENDA, NOT A BACKWARD LOOKING
ONE.
>> OKAY.
AND BY THE WAY, RIGHT TO NOTE
THE DIFFERENT APPROACHES THAT
THOSE REPUBLICAN CANDIDATES TOOK
IN VIRGINIA AND NEW JERSEY.
BUT THE NATIONAL PARTY IS VERY
DIFFERENT.
AS YOU KNOW, TWO-THIRDS OF HOUSE
MEMBERS, THE DAY, THE NIGHT OF
THE INSURRECTION STILL VOTED TO
DECERTIFY THE ELECTION.
IT HAS BECOME A NEW LITMUS TEST
FOR GOP CANDIDATES, PARTICULARLY
IN THE HOUSE, TO CONTINUE THAT
ELECTION LIE.
I GET THE POINT OF YOUR BOOK
HERE, TO YOUR CREDIT, SAYING THE
PARTY HAS TO MOVE ON.
IT IS NOT, THOUGH.
SO I WONDER WOULD YOU STAY IN
THE PARTY IF IT DOESN'T MOVE ON?
>> LISTEN, I'M A REPUBLICAN,
JIM, I'VE BEEN A REPUBLICAN MY
WHOLE LIFE.
THIS IS A FIGHT WORTH HAVING.
IT IS A FIGHT WORTH HAVING TO BE
A STRONG VIABLE COUNTERWEIGHT TO
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
AND I JUST GIVE YOU A BIT OF
VERY RECENT NEWS.
IN THE DES MOINES REGISTER POLL
THAT JUST CAME OUT YESTERDAY,
THEY ASKED IOWA REPUBLICANS AND
YOU KNOW, JIM, IOWA REPUBLICANS
ARE SOME OF THE MOST
CONSERVATIVE REPUBLICANS IN
AMERICA.
AND THEY ASKED THEM, WHERE IS
YOUR PRIMARY LOYALTY TO THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY, OR TO DONALD
TRUMP?
62% OF IOWA REPUBLICANS SAID TO
THE REPUBLICAN PARTY, ONLY 26%
SAID TO DONALD TRUMP.
AND, LOOK, THERE ARE MANY THINGS
AS YOU WELL NOTED AT THE TOP, I
SUPPORTED THE FORMER PRESIDENT,
I WAS THE FIRST ONE TO COME OUT
AND DO IT, I SUPPORTED MANY OF
HIS POLICIES.
BUT WHEN WE HAD DISAGREEMENTS, I
WAS HIS FRIEND FOR 20 YEARS, AND
I TOLD HIM WHAT THOSE
DISAGREEMENTS WERE, PRIVATELY
AND PUBLICLY.
DES MOINES REGISTER POLL, JIM,
IT TELLS YOU SOMETHING
DIFFERENT, WE NEED TO WIN
ELECTIONS AGAIN AND TO WIN
ELECTIONS AGAIN WE HAVE TO START
SPEAKING DIRECTLY TO THE
CONCERNS OF THE AMERICAN PEOPLE,
NOT ABOUT THE PAST.
>> THAT POLL NOTWITHSTANDING, I
SHOULD NOTE NATIONAL POLLS SHOW
A LARGE MAJORITY OF REPUBLICANS
SUPPORT TRUMP AS THE NOMINEE.
I WANT TO NOTE SOME OF YOUR
FELLOW REPUBLICANS HAVE TAKEN
AIM AT YOU.
I'LL NOTE ADAM KINZINGER, HE
TWEETED THIS SAYING YOU'RE
PLAYING BOTH SIDES.
CHRIS CHRISTIE PRETENDS TO BE
BOTH ANTI-TRUMP AND PRO-TRUMP.
ON FOX NEWS, YOU SAID YOU'RE
STILL FRIENDS WITH TRUMP, BUT
YOU'RE A FRIEND WHO TELLS HIM
THE TRUTH.
AND AS YOU KNOW, TRUMP IS AN ALL
IN OR ALL OUT GUY.
WE HAVE SEEN THIS WITH A WHOLE
HOST OF FOLKS WHO PLEDGED
LOYALTY TO HIM, BUT HE IN EFFECT
EXILED WHEN THEY GOT ON THE
OTHER SIDE OF HIM ON EVEN A
SINGLE ISSUE.
I WONDER WHAT KIND OF COMPROMISE
DO YOU PLAN TO STRIKE WITH
TRUMP?
>> THAT HASN'T BEEN MY
EXPERIENCE.
I'VE BEEN FRIENDS WITH HIM FOR
20 YEARS AND WE DISAGREED ANY
NUMBER OF TIMES, PRIVATELY AND
PUBLICLY, AND WE REMAINED FRIEND
S OVER THESE 20 YEARYEARS.
IT IS NOT MY EXPERIENCE.
WITH ALL DUE RESPECT TO ADAM
KINZINGER, HE DOESN'T KNOW
DONALD TRUMP THE WAY I'VE KNOWN
HIM OVER THE YEARS AND HAD THE
EXPERIENCE I HAD.
IN THE END, WHAT I'M SAYING IS
THE FORMER PRESIDENT NEEDS TO
UNDERSTAND THAT THE ELECTION IS
OVER, AND THAT EXACTING
VENDETTAS AND REVENGE FOR PEOPLE
WHO DON'T BELIEVE THAT THE
ELECTION WAS STOLEN AND THE
FACTS PROVE IT WAS NOT, THAT'S
NOT THE WAY FOR US TO WIN
ELECTIONS IN THE FUTURE.
>> HE HAS NOT DONE THAT.
>> WE NEED TO BE TALKING ABOUT
THE ISSUES AND WE SHOULD BE
TALKING ABOUT THE ISSUES THAT
JOE BIDEN AND KAMALA HARRIS ARE
PUTTING FORWARD RIGHT NOW AS
THEIR PRESCRIPTION FOR THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE, BECAUSE IF YOU
LOOK AT POLLS THERE, JIM,
AMERICAN PEOPLE AREN'T LOVING
THAT EITHER.
>> I GET IT.
BUT TO YOUR POINT ABOUT TRUMP,
TRUMP HAS NOT GIVEN UP THE BIG
LIE BY ANY MEANS.
HE SPREADS IT EVERY DAY.
DOUBLES DOWN.
BY THE WAY, HE ATTACKS PEOPLE,
YOU AND HE HAD A VERY PUBLIC
DISAGREEMENT JUST LAST WEEK WHEN
YOU WENT BEFORE THE REPUBLICAN
JEWISH CONGRESS AND MADE THE
SAME POINT AND HE CAME AFTER
YOU.
RIGHT.
SO MY QUESTION TO YOU IS, IF
TRUMP DOES NOT CHANGE HIS TUNE
ON THAT ESSENTIAL CLAIM THAT THE
ELECTION WAS STOLEN, WILL YOU
WITHHOLD SUPPORT FOR HIM?
SHOULD HE CHOOSE TO RUN IN 2024?
>> I MAY CHOOSE TO RUN IN 2024.
SO WHO KNOWS.
I MAY CHOOSE TO RUN IN 2024.
WHO KNOWS WHAT IS GOING TO
HAPPEN.
YES, THE PRESIDENT SENT OUT A
NEGATIVE STATEMENT ABOUT ME LAST
WEEK AFTER MY REPUBLICAN JEWISH
COALITION SPEECH AND LOOK AT ME.
I'M STILL STANDING, ALIVE AND ON
YOUR PROGRAM.
AND SO, YOU KNOW THIS IS NOT A
DEATH SENTENCE FOR ANYBODY.
IT IS A DISAGREEMENT.
AND I HAVE A DISAGREEMENT WITH
HIM ON THIS ISSUE.
WE HAVE AGREED ON MANY MORE
ISSUES THAN WE DISAGREED AND
THAT'S THE WAY WE NEED TO JUDGE
POLITICS IN THIS COUNTRY.
WE HAVE TO STOP MAKING IT BE
WHETHER IT IS ANY POLITICAL
CANDIDATE, OR FIGURE MAKING IT
THIS WAY OR THE MEDIA MAKING IT
THIS WAY THAT YOU HAVE TO BE ALL
IN OR ALL OUT.
I CAN TELL YOU, JIM, THE ONLY
POLITICAL CANDIDATE IN MY LIFE
I'VE AGREED WITH 100% OF THE
TIME IS ME.
OTHERWISE, IF THAT'S THE LITMUS
TEST, WE'LL NEVER FIND ANYBODY
THAT WAY.
>> IF YOU RUN IN 2024, IF YOU
FOLLOW THROUGH ON THAT, TRUMP
RUNS, TRUMP BEATS YOU FOR THE
NOMINATION, DO YOU SUPPORT HIM
IN 2024?
>> YOU KNOW, WHO KNOWS, JIM.
WHO KNOWS.
AND, YOU KNOW, MY --
>> YOU HAVE FUNDAMENTALLY
DIFFERENT VIEWS OF THE PAEFRT
PARTY AND THE COUNTRY.
YOU HAVE FUNDAMENTALLY DIFFERENT
VIEWS ABOUT THE STATE OF
AMERICAN ELECTORAL POLITICS.
IT IS A BASIC QUESTION.
COULD YOU SUPPORT THAT?
>> WE DO HAVE FUNDAMENTALLY
DIFFERENT VIEWS.
AND IF WE WERE TO EVER RUN
AGAINST EACH OTHER AGAIN, WE
WOULD DEBATE OUT THE
FUNDAMENTALLY DIFFERENT VIEWS.
WHAT HAPPENS AFTER THAT, WHO
KNOWS, JIM.
I WON'T LOOK INTO THE CRYSTAL
BALL THIS MORNING.
I'VE BEEN VERY CLEAR IN THE BOOK
AND IN MY ANSWERS TO YOUR
QUESTIONS TODAY ABOUT THE ISSUE
REGARDING THE ELECTION.
THE ELECTION WAS NOT STOLEN,
THERE IS NO EVIDENCE TO SUPPORT
THAT.
BY THE WAY, I SIT IN ON ELECTION
NIGHT ON ABC AFTER HE GAVE HIS
TALK THAT YOU CANNOT SAY THESE
THINGS WITHOUT EVIDENCE.
THAT'S THE OLD PROSECUTOR IN ME.
WHAT OUR PARTY NEEDS TO
UNDERSTAND AND WHAT I'M TRYING
TO ADVOCATE IN THIS BOOK IS THAT
IF WE WANT TO DO WHAT POLITICAL
PARTIES ARE MEANT TO DO, WIN
ELECTIONS AND THEN GET A CHANCE
TO GOVERN, WE HAVE TO SPEAK TO
THE CONCERNS OF THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE, STOP REPUBLICAN ON
REPUBLICAN VIOLENCE AND TALK
ABOUT OUR DIFFERENCES WITH JOE
BIDEN, KAMALA HARRIS AND
CONGRESSIONAL DEMOCRATS.
WE DO THAT, WE HAVE A CHANCE TO
WIN ELECTIONS LIKE WE WON IT IN
VIRGINIA AND SEATS IN NEW
JERSEY, TWO BLUE STATES, TWO
WEEKS AGO.
>> TO YOUR POINT, YOU SAY THIS
IN YOUR BOOK, WE ANNOUNCED THE
CONSPIRACY THEORIES AND TRUTH
DENIERS, THE ONES WHO KNOW
BETTER AND THE ONES WHO ARE JUST
PLAIN NUTS.
GOVERNOR